الجيش السوداني يعني اقوى من ناحيه
التسليح من ناحيه الخبره حتى من ناحيه
ربما القدره او الصلاحيه في الاستعانه
بدوله اخرى لانه لا ننسى ان الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني العميد نبيل عبد الله قد
صرح بانه من حق القوات المسلحه السودانيه
ان تتعاون مع اي دوله في المنطقه
ما نعلم ذلك انا في تقدير انا في تقديري
ان ظل يلاحق مصر مثلا يعني كانت هناك حروف
في زمن الرئيس الاسبق جعفر النميري في
العام 70 تم ضرب
تم استخدام المصري ويقال ان الرئيس الراحل
حسني مبارك كان يقود احدى الط
ائرات ظلت هذه على عقده التاريخ السوداني
انا اعتقد ان جمهوريه مصر المشاركه في
هكذا مع اي انظمه ايا كانت
شكلها وايا كانت طبيعتها اشراك القوات
المصريه بالدخول في السودان انا اعتقد انه
سيظل ايضا عقده
تلاحق العلاقه
ما انا هذه التجارب انا في تقديري
الحكومات
انه الان اصبح لديها اسرى يعني
تم نعم بطبيعه الحال انا ارجح جهه التي
قمزت قوات الدعم في قناتها هنا وهو يتحدث
عن ان هناك طيران اجنبي الان يتدخل في
العمليات العسكريه انا في تقديري ان
الارجح والاخر هو ان يكون الطرف المصري
والطالما ان هناك قاعده جويه منذ اكثر من
عام ظلت ظلت طيران فيها وهناك مصريين
شاهدناهم باميهمنا
في هذه المواجهه العسكريه
وتم اعتزار فائده دعم السريع لنصف ان
ابنائكم يمكن استردادهم
ايضا تحدثوا عن مطلب
في تقديري ان
راينا الاحوال هو لو ان مصر ايضا كرر
التجربه العام انا اعتقد انها ستعمق
الفجوه النفسيه بينها وبين شعب طالما ان
الصراع سوداني سوداني التدخلات الخارجيه
هناك حساسيه عاليه تجاهها حتى التدخلات
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه
نعم قوه الدعم السريع ايضا لها امتداد
ودعم خارجي
نعم نعم حتى حتى حتى العلاقات التي كانت
بين قوات الدعم الشريره ومجموعه والحديث
الكثير الذي يدور عن هذا الامر انا
بتقديري انها كلها تجربه بمجملها تجربه
بمجملها ما بعد الحادي عشر من ابريل حتى
ما قبل عندما طلب الرئيس المخلوع عمر
البشير من بلازمير ان يبسط عليه حمايه من
الامريكان انا بتغميري ان هذه الاشياء
بتكوين الشخصيه السودانيه وطبيعه الانسان
السوداني لا يقبل لا يقبل يمكن ان يقبل
الصراع والتطاحل بين بعضهم البعض لكن لا
يقبلوا اصلا تدخلات بهذه الاستعانه
بالاجنبي ايا كان خافض الاستعانه بدات
باستخدام اول
تستعين بالاخر لكي تستقوي به على السودان
مثل هذه القضيه قضيه مغلقه ومنزعجه وانا
في تقديري